Speaker 1: We have not really talked about
COVID for a while because it's become kind
of background noise to so many people, whether
that's right or wrong, I'm not saying.
But it has become background noise to a large
share of the United States.
But we're currently in the middle of a wave
so massive that the real number of infections
might be 500,000 infections per day already.
Already now.
And you might say, well, but hold on a second,
David.
Those aren't the official numbers right now.
And you would be absolutely correct.
But I'll explain.
If you look at the official case numbers,
you'll see that we're back up to about 100,000
cases per day.
In fact, if I look at the absolute newest
numbers, we're at about 99,500 cases per day.
So call it 100,000 cases per day.
But we're now at a point where there's just
a ton of sort of like who cares around the
country?
And the belief is that we're capturing maybe
only one out of five actual infections that
we have.
Now, remember, a case is you've got a positive
test, an infection is someone has the virus,
whether it shows up as a positive test or
not.
And there's a few different reasons that we
are not capturing nearly all of the infections.
Number one, many people are just no longer
getting tested when they have symptoms.
Oh, I've got symptoms.
It's probably COVID or not.
I don't know.
But I'm just staying home.
Or maybe I'm not even staying home if you're
less responsible or unable to.
But that's an infection and it's not showing
up as a case.
That's that's first and foremost.
Number two, we have a ton of people getting
home tests.
And these home tests, there's nothing magical.
There's no Wi-Fi, Bluetooth or RFID in your
home test.
If you test positive on a home test and you
don't report it anywhere, that also doesn't
show up in the case numbers, even though it's
an infection.
And then thirdly, there's essentially no more
testing of asymptomatic people going on very
sparingly.
There are places that are doing surveillance
testing, meaning everybody gets tested on
some period of time, friends of mine and family
who work in academic settings.
Some of them say, yeah, we get tested once
a week or twice a week just to keep the campus
sort of in a regular testing mode.
But that's basically gone away.
And so asymptomatic people are essentially
not showing up anywhere.
And so to get the real number of infections,
we have to multiply by roughly five, says
Dr. Eric Topol, who has a great Twitter on
COVID stuff.
And he's been a guest on this show, meaning
that our 100,000 official cases per day probably
means around half a million actual infections
per day, which is just an incredible number.
Now, the good news so far is that if we look
at deaths, deaths continue to decline.
And we typically believe there's about a three
or four week delay from when cases increase
before you see an increase in deaths.
And it's been two months of increasing cases
and deaths continue to decline now down technically
below the level of flu deaths in the United
States, in the sense that if in the average
oh, I'm sorry, no, that's completely wrong,
but I apologize.
That's not true at all.
We average about a thousand flu I'm sorry,
a hundred flu deaths a day in an average flu
season and word about 250 COVID deaths a day.
So still two and a half times as many COVID
deaths as flu deaths.
But hospitalizations are going up.
So it is very it's conceivable and plausible
that soon we are going to see the death numbers
go up as well.
We're already seeing a 20% increase in hospitalizations.
Now, in the meantime, we are learning many
new things about COVID.
One of those is not a good piece of news.
It's that COVID is now evolving quickly enough
with enough variants that are we've had variants
forever, but now the variants actually seem
to slightly more regularly outcompete each
other, as Dr. Eric Topol has written about.
And this means that more quickly we are getting
variants that can break through boosters and
can break through natural immunity as well
to reinfect people potentially multiple times
per year.
That's very, very much not good.
Now, there is one bit of good news if we want
to look for one, which is that we're currently
in what's been colloquially called Wave five
or also known as the Bay four slash Bay five
wave.
Remember we had the original micron wave and
then the secondary.
Okay, so now we're on Bay four and Bay five
variants.
If you look at South Africa, you see that
this Wave five has already leveled off and
started to decline.
And so oftentimes what happens in South Africa
happens.
In the United States somewhere around six,
eight, ten weeks, 6 to 8 weeks later.
And we hope that that's the case and that
this is the peak.
But this is these are incredible numbers.
Half a million infections believed per day.
And one other element of this that's a bit
concerning is we may already be kind of behind
on vaccines, the American tailored vaccine,
which is going to be tailored to the first
American variant back from late November,
early December 2021.
That vaccine is going to be out in a couple
of months, and by then we're going to be like
five variants away.
So so from that.
So there's a real question as to whether we
can even keep up or catch up when it comes
to vaccination, because it takes a while to
get the vaccines updated.
So that's what's going on.
I'd be curious to hear from you.
Leave a comment, send an email, send a tweet.
At this point, are you taking any COVID precautions
at all?
I know many people in the audience are taking
full precautions and many people in the audience
are taking absolutely no precautions at this
point in time.
As of what I heard from you guys about a couple
of months ago, let me know where you are right
now